MALE SPEAKER: Good afternoon.
Welcome to Talks at Google
in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Today it's my great pleasure
to introduce Robert Shiller.
Dr. Shiller is Sterling
Professor of Economics at Yale
and winner of the 2013
Nobel Prize in economics.
He's the author of the New York
Times best seller "Irrational
Exuberance," and with George
Akerlof, also a Nobel winner,
he's coauthored a previous
book in addition to today's.
Dr. Shiller joins
us today to discuss
the provocatively titled
"Phishing for Fools:
The Economics of
Manipulation and Deception."
As he says in the
book, "Competitive
markets by their very nature
spawn deception and trickery
as a result of the same
profit motives that
give us our prosperity."
I'll let him take it from there.
Please join me in
welcoming Bob Shiller.
[APPLAUSE]
ROBERT SHILLER: Thank you.
Jonathan told me
that you recently had
Dick Thaler in the same series.
That's interesting to me.
Dick is an old
colleague of mine.
We've been running a
behavioral economics workshop
at the NBER, which is right
near here, for 25 years.
And he wrote a book called
"Nudge" with Cass Sunstein
about government policy.
And the book I'm
going to talk about
could be considered
the anti "Nudge."
It's kind of the opposite.
The presumption was that nudges
are used for good purposes,
and maybe they are.
Do you know what a nudge is?
This is a new-- I'm drifting
from my prepared talk.
We're all critical
of economists.
There aren't any economist
here, probably, right?
So economists have
adopted a canonical model
of an economy consisting of self
interested, utility maximizing
individuals who take
prices as a given
and maximize their
utility individually.
And that leaves to
some kind of optimality
ultimately in the
equilibrium that follows.
So both Thaler and I are
critical of that model
that underlies economics.
And our criticism
has something to do
with the field of psychology,
of neuroscience, sociology,
which have a different approach
to studying human nature.
I feel a little uncomfortable
talking at Google.
I don't think I prepared
adequately for you.
That's because a lot of what
we talk about is marketing,
and we have an
uncomfortable relationship
to marketing as you'll see.
Not necessarily negative,
but just uncomfortable.
And I don't know what
Google, isn't Google,
there's different
ways of looking at it.
By the way, you're Google
not Alphabet, right?
AUDIENCE: There's
some Alphabet here.
ROBERT SHILLER:
I'm all confused.
I'm talking to an
organization in transition.
I don't know how to.
But I was thinking, I think of
you as a search engine company,
but that's very narrow.
But I think maybe it's better
to think of you as a marketing
company.
Is that a good?
You're a big data company,
and we have mixed feelings
about all of these things.
[LAUGHTER]
So I thought I should start
by saying that I've already
thought of Google as an
ethical company in this space.
So just did a test this morning.
I went on to
news.google.com, and I just
looked at what came up.
And there was, the way
my computer does it,
I saw a big news story
about Hurricane Patrick,
which is the biggest
hurricane ever that's
about to hit Mexico.
That was the Google story.
And then to compare that
I went, can I say it here?
Bing.
[LAUGHTER]
Now their screen, the
lead story in their screen
was lone gunman kills one person
at Tennessee State University
after a dice game.
OK.
Now that's sort of all
right as news, but I think,
that's what we're going to
call phishing in my mind.
We use the word
phishing in our title,
you see it there, as a
metaphor for a broader
range of deception.
So think about Bing putting
that story on as the lead story.
Is that really high
minded news reporting?
Well, to me it seems
not, especially
since there's now
a new website, I
forget the name, that
lists every mass shooting.
And it turns out if they
define a mass shooting
as, this didn't qualify but,
four people killed at least.
And there's one every
day in the United States.
So it's like why,
is this really news?
And then at the bottom
left of the Bing screen,
there was a news
story, and the title
was "Drunken man breaks in by
mistake to a neighbor's house
and crawls into bed
with two young girls."
Now that is definitely
not a news story
for me in the sense that
it's wasting my time.
So I've had this good
feeling about Google, largely
from that, well, in many things.
So what this book is about
is about what's really,
it's a certain kind of general
problem with free market,
unregulated economies.
And by the way, the
co-author, George Akerlof
is as you mentioned is my
coauthor on another book,
he to me is a very
independent thinking person.
I wanted to write a book with
him not quite knowing where
it would go, because I
like working with people
who think differently.
And both he and I
have always felt
somewhat critical about what
goes on in our profession.
The point is to bring that out.
Now, the problem--
or also, what is
a fool, that's our coined word.
That's someone who may
be very intelligent,
but doesn't appreciate how much
manipulation and deception is
being foisted on him.
So the idea of our
book is that we
would talk about many
different kinds of manipulation
and deception.
Talk about it from
a behavioral, from
a psychological standpoint.
And another thing about our book
is that we're different from,
there's a long history of books
on this topic as you may know.
We wanted to take it from a
more economic perspective.
With both George Akerlof and
I, when we were teenagers,
we didn't know each other then,
we read Vance Packard's book
"The Hidden Persuaders."
Do you know this book?
It was a bestseller
in the 1950s.
It detailed how advertisers
use psychology to trick you.
And you are already aware that
they do that sometimes, but you
read Vance Packard's book,
and it comes across looking
much more frequent.
The problem with
Vance Packard's book,
though, is that it doesn't
have any economics in it,
and it seems to
portray the marketers
as an evil conspiracy.
And we didn't feel that that
was the right way to look at it.
So our book is about what we
call a "phishing equilibrium."
It's not that people
are evil, it's
that we have a market
system that allows,
that almost forces
people to play the tricks
that we don't like, and it's
called competitive pressures.
So the theory of
competitive equilibrium
is sometimes connected to
Darwin's theory of evolution,
constant pressure on
businesses to make profits,
and that means
then that they will
be very efficient, because
they will be struggling hard
to succeed.
But the problem
is that they might
have to be dishonest
within subtle,
it has to be within
the law, of course.
But this more subtle
form of dishonesty
underlies problems that
we see in free markets.
We're going to come
around at the end
to a plea for civil
society, or an argument
that civil society
is what really
matters in a successful
free market economy.
By the way, I should
add since I'm here,
I believe in free
markets, and in fact, I
have something of an
entrepreneurial history.
I started with Case
and Weiss, a company
called Case, Shiller,
Weiss in 1991
that produced home price
indices and valuations.
We were ahead of Zillow.
We had an online in the mid
1990s home valuation service.
And the outcome wasn't
as successful as Zillow,
but we sold our company in 2002.
And now Core Logic is
continuing our index production.
And we've established a futures
market for single family homes
based on our indexes,
and that's still
going, not hugely successful,
but Standard and Poor's
publishes our indexes.
So that was our
successful venture.
Then we had an unsuccessful one
that I won't tell you about.
But it may not be
unsuccessful, because I
think that what we
tried, which was
to create markets
for real estate
and oil and other maybe GDP
is still being talked about.
I think the story
is not over yet.
So I'm really pro free markets
and pro entrepreneurship.
This is just a, what
I'm talking about,
what we're talking about in this
book is just a dent into that.
And it's don't go too
far with the belief
in that just self interest will
promote good economic outcomes.
So I think that one thing that
economists don't recognize
is how the world is
driven by social movements
and thought leaders.
And they tend to,
one of the problems
is that, there's many
problems that are,
but in terms of our
thinking as academics,
there's a tendency to be
affected by prevailing theory.
Something that Daniel Kahneman
calls theory induced blindness.
A theory becomes established
as part of a movement,
and then it gets tremendous
prestige for a while,
and then it becomes overrated.
And I think what
George and I want
to argue against in our
book is the overratedness
of the free market
capitalism idea.
So let me step back
and think about, I
don't know if any of you had
graduate training in economics.
Probably some of you have
had undergraduate training.
There is one of
the core elements
that you will be taught
in a economic theory
course will be something
called the fundamental theorem
of welfare economics.
Do you know this?
At least one of you doesn't.
Whether you've heard of the
exact theorem is irrelevant.
I think you've heard of the
general sense of conclusion
from it.
The fundamental theorem
of welfare economics,
which you can find in
micro theory textbooks,
is a mathematical
theorem that describes
a competitive equilibrium.
You assume that each individual
is completely selfish, only
interested in
himself or herself,
and this person
maximizes utilities
subject to a budget constraint.
They're also producers that
produce the commodities,
and they maximize their profits
subject to a budget constraint.
But there is no social
feeling whatsoever.
Everyone does it for
personal reward only.
The outcome, the theorem says,
is in a competitive equilibrium
if there are no externalities,
that the allocation of goods
and services will
be Pareto optimal.
You ever heard of this term?
Some of you have.
Vilfredo Pareto was
an economic theorist
who flourished around 1900.
And he actually anticipated
the fundamental theorem
of welfare economics, but
didn't prove it adequately.
The Pareto optimality
means there is no way
to make everyone better off.
You can redistribute income, you
can take from one to another,
and that will make one better
off and the other worse off,
but there is no
way in equilibrium
to make everyone better off.
Moreover, this became accepted
by economics departments
who then thought, well,
redistribution is not
our department.
Should we take from the rich and
give to the poor, for example.
That's philosophy
department stuff.
Economists redefine
themselves in the 20th century
as technicians.
Right, they say, should
we take from the rich
and give to the poor.
That's not science,
that's philosophy.
That's ethics or morals.
We are called in to talk about
is the economy functioning
well, and that functioning
means Pareto efficiency.
So I think that the economics
departments of the world
became less philosophical, less
moral in their orientation,
less interested in
how people behave.
They had this
mathematical framework,
which had nothing about
people except that there
are relentlessly selfish.
They then dragged out of
Adam Smith, who in 1776 wrote
the classic of all time
in economics, the book,
"The Wealth of Nations."
And there is a
quote they pull out
one place in this book
where Adam Smith seems
to think that completely selfish
behavior within the limits
of a market economy that upholds
property rights is optimal.
He said something
like, I'm trying
to remember the
exact quote, but he
said, "It's not to the
beneficence of the providers
of food that I get my dinner.
The Baker, the brewer,
and the butcher
provide my dinner, because of
my paying them for what they do,
not out of any concern for me."
And then Adam Smith went
on to say, you know,
I get more from
those selfish people
than I get from all the social
reformers of the world who
don't seem to make
any difference.
That's all talk.
That was a very loose
quote of Adam Smith.
But you know what?
These are extreme views.
And even Adam Smith
didn't believe that,
because if you look in
other parts of his work,
he wrote another book in 1759
called "The Theory of Moral
Sentiments."
And in that book, he said
that people are not selfish.
They have some aspects
of selfishness,
but they're inherently
social creatures.
Very interesting book,
his 1759 book, by the way.
Vilfredo Pareto who
named Pareto optimality,
himself didn't believe it.
In fact, he dropped
out of economics,
and he spent the last
30 years of his life
as a sociologist trying
to understand society.
I think that there is something
wrong with this theory.
In 1918-- you see I have a
long time frame of history.
I read these old ideas, and I
find it's useful to do that.
Go back 100 or 200
years, they have
ideas that we've forgotten.
Professor Irving Fisher
at Yale University
said that this whole
thing about utility
that economists talk
about, it's not right.
People don't maximize
their utility.
The word utility goes back to
the philosopher Jeremy Bentham
who said all philosophy
should be oriented toward,
all morality should be
oriented toward utility.
But utility, he said, meant
something like the human well
being, human fulfilment.
Irving Fisher said, that's
not what people maximize.
They maximize, he said we
need another word for it.
And he couldn't figure out
a really good word for,
it's not in a language,
so he coined one.
And he said it's wantability.
What you maximize
is not your utility,
it's what you want at the moment
that you make the purchase.
That term, by the way
I love Google Trends,
Google Ngrams has changed
my life, because I always
look up any idea.
So I looked up wantability
on Google Ngrams,
and I find his word did
not exist before 1918.
It exploded into usage
for the next 20 years,
and then has exponentially
decayed since then.
Now if you teach micro
theory in a university,
it's kind of a
difficult assignment,
because it's supposed to be some
classical theory that everyone
should know.
And it's a little bit
depressing to have
to teach this old stuff.
So nobody's really interested,
oh, I'm exaggerating.
But you'll teach the fundamental
theorem of welfare economics
with reverence and never come
back to distortions in it.
Now here what
we're talking about
is a phishing equilibrium.
I think the simplest example,
because you've likely
already heard of it, but
it's a very minor example,
but I'll start with this, is
the candy bars at the checkout
counter.
Have you ever noticed
at a grocery store
when you go to the
checkout, you're
standing in line
waiting to, now it
might be a
computerized checkout,
but it would be still
standing in line for a while,
they have candy
bars right there.
So why is this?
Well, about 30 years ago some
social reformers and thought
leaders decided to
make a case about this.
You know why they
put them there.
It's because you don't go to
the grocery store intending
to buy candy bars, and
in fact, you probably
have an idea that I'm
not going to buy that.
But now they put them right in
front of you at the worst time,
right at the end of
your shopping trip
when you're standing
there in line.
Moreover, many people go to
the store with young children.
Now you've been shopping for 45
minutes, they're getting tired,
and now you're putting
them in the experience
of standing in line.
It's a most unpleasant ending.
So they know that
you're vulnerable,
and they put it there.
Several decades ago
a number of stores
announced that they
would not do that,
because there seemed to be a
public reaction against it.
However, if you
look now at stores,
it's all happening, it's all
back, the candy bars are back.
And my colleague
George points out
that the children's candy
is put at children's eye
level in the store.
So this is just
illustrating what I
mean by a phishing equilibrium.
Imagine that you took a job
as a manager of a supermarket.
Do you think you would do this?
I've pointed out that
you are in a sense
exploiting your customers by
putting candy bars right there.
It's almost evil, but it's not.
The outrage has passed,
it had its moment,
and now it's now it's faded.
And so, would you do it?
Well, the grocery
store business happens
to be a highly competitive.
It's not a mostly
innovative business.
There's a lot of competitors.
There's no organizational
slack, which gives you freedom.
If you became a manager
of a grocery store,
you would probably become
very quickly conscious
that other grocery stores go
out of business all the time.
Your profit margin
is something like 2%.
You can't monkey around
too much without risking
the whole enterprise.
So you probably would
do it, too, right?
The other thing is
that managers learn
that the best way to
manage if in doubt, imitate
what other people are doing.
You assume that
they've experimented.
It's costly for
me to experiment.
Apparently, everyone puts
candy bars at the checkout,
so I will do that too.
Now I've picked a very
minor example about this.
What we did in our book is
also somewhat similar to what
Vance Packard and
others have done
is just give a lot of examples.
Our examples come from all
different times in history.
Some of them-- let me just
give you a couple of examples.
One of them is, there's a
book by Natasha Schull called
"Addiction by Design," and
it's about slot machines.
It's really about
machine gambling.
She points out that gambling
has changed in recent decades,
and it's become more
machine oriented.
That is slot machines are rising
as a share of total profits
for gambling enterprises.
And why is that?
Well, she presents
an analysis saying
that people are more
vulnerable toward addiction
when they are under the
control of a machine.
So gambling is less and less.
I'm going to have some friends
over, and we'll play cards,
we'll play a little poker, which
would be a social environment.
When they first discovered
slot machines in the 1890s,
slot machines were found to be
addictive to a small percent
of the population.
They seemed to
just keep doing it.
Have you ever noticed
these people in a casino?
I think it has something
to do with a brain bug.
Another book, I like
books, so I'm mentioning,
there is a book by
neuroscientists Dean Buonomano
called "Brain Bugs."
His premise is that the
brain is a computer,
and it has a built
in program as well as
adjustments that you add as a
part of your education later.
But the built in
program has bugs in it.
It's a product of Darwinian
evolution, but only incomplete.
Evolution is much slower
than computer programs
are and writing code, and
so there are lots of bugs.
The book details all the bugs.
And I think it's
interesting reading.
It's a funny perspective
to take on yourself.
Well, apparently this
slot machine addiction
has something to do
with a bug in the reward
system in the brain that
for some people encourages
repetitive behavior.
I used to code in Fortran,
so I kind of think of it
as being stuck in a do loop.
[LAUGHTER]
So according to Natasha Schull,
researchers on slot machines
have tried to figure out what
makes for a successful slot
machine.
And they found out that I
guess the optimal interval
between gambles is
3 and 1/2 seconds.
So they try to make it,
that's because it's somehow
the reward
neuroscientists have found
tends to come at the
moment of anticipation.
The work of Wolfram Schultz, so
the dopamine system sends out
signals the moment
you think I've just
placed a bet I'm hopeful.
And then that dies out after
a certain interval of time.
So if you want it to
be optimally addicting,
you have to make it
easy for the person
to keep playing bets
at that interval.
So they've eliminated the
crank that used to pull down.
That seemed to interfere
with the optimal frequency.
And another thing
they've learned
is that people are
trying to stop.
They're sitting there thinking,
you know I've lost $25 already,
maybe I should stop.
But they can't quite
bring themselves to stop.
Well, they've discovered
through research
that people who are
gambling machine addicts
tend to stop if there's anything
interrupting the flow of just
pushing, pushing, pushing.
It used to be that coins
would come out when you won,
and they'd make a loud noise
and a big spectacle and great.
But the problem is that
it disrupted the flow,
and many people would pack
up and leave at that point.
You don't want them to
pack up and leave right
when they've won something.
So they now substitute a
synthesised digital sound
of coins falling, so it
won't break the rhythm
of your keeping on betting.
They've also
discovered that people
are a little bit ashamed to be
sitting at the slot machine,
so they try to find a nook where
they are away from other people
observing them too much.
But they have a social component
to the gambling still has that.
They like to see the
excitement of the Casino.
So you optimize
the structure, so
that they have the slight
sense that they're hiding
in privacy with this machine.
Anyway, you get the idea.
I don't how you people, you're
not doing anything like this
here, right?
I hope not.
But even so, if you can
imagine taking a job designing
slot machines, you
might be affected
to do the same sort of thing.
Let me give you another example.
Coca-Cola is the most
famous beverage ever.
Why?
Now I've always wondered this,
because I never particularly
liked it.
I don't dislike it either.
I mean, it's just,
Yeah, it's fine.
But how did it get to be so big?
Well, it's a testimony
to marketing.
And the people at
Coca-Cola had a belief
that-- I'm relying this on
a book "Salt, Sugar, Fat"
by Michael Moss.
It was a best seller a year ago.
According to his
history of this,
the Coca-Cola
people were acutely
aware of the
importance of attaching
memories of good moments
to their beverage.
And they would try
to use advertising
to make a connection,
so that later on you
would just think Coca-Cola,
it's great, it's good.
Somehow, I feel good.
Now I think that what
those people did was
they did something that
was an anticipation
of modern neuroscience.
And that is that
neuroscience now
says that the human
mind as a computer
has a filing system for
memories that attach emotions
to each memory.
So I think it's a good idea to
put an emotion on every memory.
It's not a human idea,
that's an evolutionary idea.
It's like having a file cabinet
with different colored folders,
and important stuff you
put in a red folder,
so it attaches an emotion.
Another is starting to see
that the brain is really
structured that way.
So for example, you
have the amygdala,
which is somewhere in here, that
attaches emotions to memory.
The right amygdala specializes
in fear, for example.
Did any of you see the
new movie "Inside Out."
It's a children's
movie, Disney Pixar.
I went with my wife to
see it, because it's
supposed to be a
children's movie,
but I thought it was
far more interesting
than most adult movies,
most that I've seen lately.
It features an 11 year old girl.
It gives you a peek
inside her brain.
Now it's a little
bit simplified.
It says there are
five emotions, just
like there are five senses.
You know sight, hearing,
touch, smell, and taste.
There are five emotions.
They're fear, anger, joy,
disgust, and, I forget.
AUDIENCE: Anger.
ROBERT SHILLER: Anger, yes.
And so the idea is that
these are already built in.
It's the same in every culture.
And it shows, the whole
drama of this movie
is that the attachment
of emotions to memories
and the concern that the
people inside your brain
have about the dangers
of attaching emotions
to core memories, because it
can change your personality
afterward.
It's dangerous to have
negative emotions attached
to important memories.
So I think Coca Cola people
appreciated this right
from the beginning.
And it was that sort of thing.
Well, I'm giving
you some examples.
We have many other examples.
We attribute the financial
crisis recently to at least
partly to phishing.
People had the advantage of
selling certain securities.
That a lot of emotional tension
in life that people have
is running out of
money and fearing
for their possible
bankruptcy, and I
think that marketing
helps them do that.
Anyway I'm supposed to wrap up.
What I wanted to do
is get to what is our,
I don't know if I
presented this well,
but I wanted to get
to the idea that we
have about why we are
as successful as we
seem to be in this country.
What is our core
reason for success.
A view has enveloped that it
is because of our free market
institutions that
encourage entrepreneurs.
That's certainly partly right,
but is that the only thing.
Or should we, it seems like
we might be oversimplifying
to give quite so much.
So why is America
a great country?
I have a couple of suggested
readings on this, which
you can find on Google Books.
And I'm so thankful to Google,
which gives me so much help.
In 1780, I think the year
was, Benjamin Franklin wrote
a short article to be
published in Europe.
And the title of the
article was "Information
for People Contemplating
Repairing to America."
It was a description of
America in 1780 for Europeans.
And in that description
he said, "Be warned.
Your erudition will do
you nothing in America.
The Americans are
very practical people,
and they want to see results.
If you are a skilled
workman of some sort, fine,
come to America
and you'll do well.
But if you're on an aristocrat
or an artist or a philosopher,
don't come."
That's something about America.
It reflects the kind
of people who came here
and the attitude that developed.
The other one you my read
is Alexis de Tocqueville
who has a lot to say
about American character.
The point is that this country
is a success partly because
of free markets, but also
because of civil society.
And it's actions
that people have
taken to prevent the phishing
equilibrium from dominating.
So it's not just individual acts
of ethics or acts of concern.
We can exhibit, for example, the
founder of Ogilvy and Mather,
the ad agency,
Ogilvy in the 1940s
announced that his company would
not take on any more cigarette
advertisements.
I think that if you read
the medical literature
in the 20th century,
it started to become
like I have a hunch cigarette
smoking is bad for you by 1915.
By 1940 it still wasn't
proven, but someone
who read the literature would
probably say, this is it,
I'm not smoking.
It looked pretty bad.
So that's when Ogilvy pulled
out of a cigarette advertising.
But it didn't have no
effect on the outcome,
because somebody else
just goes right back in.
There's a profit to be made.
And there was a profit
to be made from phishing.
The cigarette companies tried
a strategy of sowing confusion
about tobacco.
They found that the president
of the University of Michigan,
Little, was a
skeptic and a smoker.
He loved his smoking.
And they got him to
say that no one has
proved at a statistically
significant level
that smoking is harmful.
Maybe he was right,
or maybe they
didn't understand causality
well enough to prove it.
But basically, it was a feint
to try to get people confused,
and it was for profit.
So what we really
need is somebody
who will stand above
the profit incentive
and will do something to try
to limit profit opportunities
for things that we can't stand.
And I've been
concluding my talks
by just giving a few examples
of heroes who sort of started
social movements.
And there are a
great many heroes.
What I've been doing as a game,
I've done a book tour for this.
I'll try it here, too.
The game is I'll give you
some names of famous people
who upheld morality in
business and ask you
if there's anyone
here who can tell me
who they are by their name.
Now, if you read our
book, you'll know,
but that's cheating.
So let me start with
Florence Kelley.
Anyone heard of her?
As anticipated, no one has.
Florence Kelley in 1899 set up
the National Consumers League,
which tested products for
safety and put a white label,
this was a nonprofit,
a white label
on products that were safe.
William Henry Merrill, now
this is not the Merrill Lynch
Merrill.
Again no one.
In 1893 he was an
electrician who
was asked to inspect the
electricity at the Chicago
World's Fair palace
of electricity.
It was really an
exciting display
of what things were going
to come through electricity,
but it was unsafe.
Their wiring wasn't
right, so he decided
to set up a nonprofit called
United Laboratories or UL,
and they would put their
mark on safe products.
This worked, because it
made it impossible to phish.
The word got out, don't
buy if it doesn't say UL,
and that stopped certain
kinds of phishing.
By the way, UL made
a corporate change
just as Google has in this month
in 2012, it went for profit.
I believe it's still
doing the same business,
and it's the same socially
conscious business.
Another hero, Alice Lakey
and Harvey Washington Wiley.
OK, 0.
I've done this before.
I hope I'm not offending you.
What these people did is made
a public campaign about drugs.
They argued that
as of 1900, most
drugs that you could buy in
a drug store were fraudulent.
There was something
like Swaim's Panacea.
What is that?
First of all, it claimed
to cure any illness.
There's something
wrong about that.
And then secondly, they
tested what was in it.
And it was just ordinary
household flavoring.
It was a complete fraud.
And they said, but
what's to stop a business
from doing that?
When they advertised
in magazines,
they're telling the
magazine, don't criticize
us or we'll pull our ad.
So there's no incentive
for the advertising.
Well, maybe there
was some incentive.
But to do a testing lab
and to do-- so anyway,
they got the government to
create the Food and Drug
Administration in 1906.
Another hero, Stuart Chase
and Frederick Schlink.
OK, Stuart, they wrote
a book in the 1920s
called "Your Money's Worth."
And they said the FDA is not
enough, because they're still
monkeying with you.
They said, take the
example of toothpaste.
I'm quoting from their book.
"We go to a drug
store, and there's
10 different brands
of toothpaste,
and they all make health claims.
Maybe they're all safe,
the FDA has tested them,
but what about
those health claims?
How does anyone know?"
So they said, "We need
a regular publication
that tests products."
That was done in 1936.
That's Consumer Reports.
Finally, one more
here, Ben Bernanke.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, I guess I
don't have to tell.
But I think that he's a hero.
It's not a for profit
operation that he led,
it was the Federal Reserve.
And he probably prevented
another Great Depression,
which was based on
a loss of confidence
and a tumult within
the financial sector.
Controversial
things that he did.
So anyway, that's my view, our
view expressed in this book.
I say that our book is,
I'm already controversial.
I may have offended some of you.
It's considered unpatriotic to,
it seems considered unpatriotic
here in America
especially to say anything
in favor of any
kinds of regulation.
But I wanted to
add that I'm not,
there's a tendency to
think about free markets
versus government.
I'm not thinking so
much about government.
Those heroes I gave you were
outside of the government
except for Ben Bernanke.
The idea of civil
society is a society
with people who have
a sense of community,
a sense of responsibility
for what goes on.
They tend to view the government
as just people we hire to do
what we want as a community.
They don't allow
themselves to be
captured by propaganda,
because of their sense
of responsibility.
And they tend to
be educated people,
and they take the
effort to get knowledge.
So that's what this
book is a plea for.
Now how this fits into
Google with its big data
and its Cloud.
There's so many
things you do here,
I find it hard to summarize
what I would think.
But it seems to me
that there is already
a moral spirit at Google as I
was saying at the beginning.
And I think you have
more organizational slack
than a grocery store does.
That means you can
philosophize about the long run
future of this organization.
And you can take steps that
are maybe costly in terms
of profits today, but in the
long run are the right things
to do, and may not even be
in the long run crossly.
I'll stop with that and
open this up to questions.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: How can behavioral
economic theory influence
like what's taught
in universities?
Will it take over?
Will rational actor
eventually not be taught?
ROBERT SHILLER: Well,
I think it will always
be taught, because it's
actually a useful thing
to the rational actor,
and the idea of Pareto
optimality is worth
talking about.
But the problem with
the economics profession
now is that it like other
academic disciplines,
they get separated and isolated.
And it develops a sort
of departmental inertia.
Here's what happens.
You become the
economics department.
Now in your research.
Now you're a community.
There's a social
tendency, tribal tendency.
You start to view the psychology
department as arrival,
arrival for university funding.
And moreover, you start
developing a brand.
So you attract PhD
students, let's say,
who wanted to become
mathematical economist.
So what do you do?
You can't say, well, we've
changed our mind this year,
we're going to teach
you psychology.
That's not what they want.
They want to get jobs.
It becomes all routinized.
They want to get
jobs, so you have
to teach them what
will get them a job
in a conventional
economics department.
And also there's
this pressure to be
at the frontier that means
that you don't have time
to read other things.
So you're struggling
so hard to get
at the pinnacle of some
mathematical discourse.
You just run out of time.
By the way, there's
another interesting book,
which just came out by
Gillian Tett called "The Silo
Effect," which argues this more
generally for corporations.
Maybe this is an argument
against Alphabet, by the way.
They said, Larry
Page said it would
be neater and more incentivizing
or accountable or something
if we divide Google
into a separate unit
with separate CEOs.
But what Gillian Tett
says is that can produce
a bad outcome of too
much specialization,
and then also a kind
of culture developing
in each one of
these units that's
kind of antagonistic to
other cultures in a sense
that if you defy the
norms of your tribe,
you will be unpatriotic
in some sense.
So I haven't finished
reading her book,
bu it sounds like it's a
really important topic.
And it accounts for the kind
of errors that are commonly
made in modern society.
AUDIENCE: So because of some
of this momentum in economics
like forgetting
graduate students
that want to do
mathematical economics,
is there any math associated
with some of these more
behavioral approaches?
ROBERT SHILLER: Oh, Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can it?
ROBERT SHILLER: Yeah,
behavioral economics
has some mathematics in it.
Right, I mean you can ask
what is it that people do,
and there can be, there's
mathematical psychology.
But the problem
is it doesn't have
the elegance of general
equilibrium economic theory.
And people who
want to understand
how did this whole
set of prices get set.
Where did they come from?
Free markets generate them,
but where and how and why?
That incline, there's a sort
of wishful thinking bias that
develops if you are a theorist.
You kind of hope this
expected utility maximization
theory is right, because it
makes for a nice modeling.
If you look at what
psychologists say,
it's just too messy.
And you can't say whether
we've-- parade or optimality is
a nice concept, because it
gives you a clear conclusion.
But if people are
psychological animals,
how do we know that we've
made them better off?
I'll give you an example
that Daniel Kahneman, who
wrote a nice book,
"Thinking Fast and Slow."
He's a psychologist
interested in economics.
But one thing he did is he
questioned whether we even
know our own happiness.
You assume that people
are making purchases
to make themselves happy.
Do people know what
makes them happy?
So he did the
following experiment.
He asked subjects
to thrust their hand
into a bowl of ice
water for 60 seconds.
By the way, try that.
You won't like it.
It gets really annoying.
That was condition
A. Then condition B,
he asked them to do that
again, but actually it's
for 90 seconds.
But he's got a little
temperature raiser
in the bowl that raises the
temperature for the last 30
seconds to something
more comfortable.
And then later asks which
did you like better A or B?
Most people like B better.
That's because,
apparently their memory
is affected by the improvement.
It's been 70 seconds, now I'm
starting to feel OK again.
But they were actually
in ice water longer.
So by some objective criteria,
they should have picked A,
but they didn't.
So the question is
whether people even know
whether they're happy or not.
It's a different view.
It makes it harder to do
economics, because yeah,
the human brain is this
complicated interconnected
calculating machine.
What's good?
I don't know what's good for it.
And if people don't know,
it just kind of leaves
you inconclusive.
So economists won't like that.
AUDIENCE: It's interesting
that your heroes were not
government people.
And of course, the
defenders of pure--
ROBERT SHILLER: Ben Bernanke
was, but most weren't.
AUDIENCE: Your
free market theory
would argue that the
most extreme would
say, oh well, we don't
need government regulation,
because the markets will
pop up people like this
where there's demand for them.
I'm curious about your
general views about that.
And even professional
licensing, of course,
Milton Friedman famously
argued that not even doctors
and lawyers should be licensed.
But I'm interested in
the latest phenomenon
of this seems to be reviews.
So Amazon has
reviews of products,
Uber, Airbnb both have
reviews of both sides
of the transaction.
Google is trying to
get more reviews.
I'm curious about your thoughts
about the review phenomenon.
Obviously, it has
lots of problems,
not just organized campaigns
to do biased reviews,
but sort of the herd
instinct with reviews
and lots of other things.
Are reviews really the latest
of this heroic phenomenon
or is it all just self
deception or what's going on
with the whole review thing?
ROBERT SHILLER: Well, you raise
a lot of interesting points.
Let me start with
Milton Friedman.
In 1962 he wrote a book called
"Capitalism and Freedom" that
was actually an outgrowth of
an earlier work he'd done with,
who was at, Kuznets on
occupational licensing.
And in that book, he argued
that occupational licensing
is merely an effort
by the practitioners
to exclude competition.
So here's what happens.
The AMA goes to appear before
a medical licensing board
and argues persuasively
that something has to be,
a practice has to be prohibited
unless it's licensed.
But that in fact is
merely keeping others
out of practicing.
The outcome is that our
medical services are excellent,
but there aren't enough of
them, and they're too expensive.
He said that somehow the
community doesn't understand
that, and so it's a doop.
He's really talking
about it kind
of manipulation and deception.
But the problem
is, what would we
do about not having any
licensure for doctors?
The problem is we
know that there
is a lot of quack
medicine that could
be sold to ignorant people.
So maybe what he proposed
has never been adopted
by any country, I think.
Any advanced country has
licensing for doctors.
But another thing is I actually
like Milton Friedman and admire
his works.
What he actually
did with that book
was quite significant,
because within a few years
of the publication of that book,
the first nurse practitioner
program was started, or
a physician's assistant.
What that did is
it really increased
the supply of medical services.
The AMA back down and allowed
that a physicians assistant
could practice in the
office of a licensed MD.
The outcome of that
was the reduction
in the cost of medical
services and improved health.
So I think that the
idea that regulators
can be captured
by the regulator,
that the regulations don't
always serve the public
is correct.
But that shouldn't
be taken as a blanket
argument against regulation.
The other thing you've asked is
about reviews on websites now
that allow people to
see others comments.
I think that is a
wonderful development.
It used to be that--
our ability to shop
has become so much better.
We get the right thing.
By the way, our GDP
numbers don't reflect that.
If you were back in 1955
buying shoes that bothered you,
buying medicines
that made you sick,
things like that, because you
couldn't read those reviews,
you had a salesman
who wasn't unbiased.
That's all you could
get information from.
So I think our human
welfare has gone up
much more than GDP has gone up.
So there's a real question
about the productivity numbers
and the outcome numbers.
So what you talk about
are wonderful things.
But offsetting that there are
risks on the other side that
phishing that is malicious can
be pursued more dramatically.
Well, that's why we use that
word phishing and with a "ph."
It goes both ways.
I'm reminded that ISIS is
a product of the internet.
Apparently, their ability--
the whole business model
of the Islamic State
is to recruit fanatics
from all over the world.
And they have a
way to do that now.
And it's creating
a real problem.
So I don't know where
all this is going net,
but I think it's important
that people at Google
maintain a sort of
philosophic and moral stance
about what they do.
And they already are doing that
as I said at the beginning,
and it is important
to keep that up.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I
have two comments.
One is about physicians
and licensing.
I once proposed
to a friend who's
a physician that that
was a means of limiting
the number of doctors
and keeping costs up.
And she told me that, well,
actually it's the opposite.
In the cities where we have
more doctors per capita,
the medical expenses
are much higher.
And so the more
doctors you have,
the more you spend on them.
ROBERT SHILLER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And so
I have a question,
what you think of that.
And then I have another
question follow up,
which is in the press we've
seen a lot of articles
recently about
the cost of drugs,
and how drug companies are
buying up old generic drugs
and combining them
in interesting ways,
and then charging
essentially whatever
they want for them, because
they are the only supplier.
They really have a monopoly.
And I'm curious how you
think the government
or the population as a whole
should deal with that issue.
ROBERT SHILLER: Yeah, OK,
well, first thing there
is a natural moral hazard
in the medical profession
that doctors will recommend
surgery that's not necessary,
because they want
to make the money.
And you as a client have
no ability to judge.
That apparently goes on.
Similar things happen in
now financial professions.
Financial advisors
will steer you
to client the products that
charge huge management fees
for questionable activities.
These are all part of
the phishing equilibrium.
So what do we do about that?
Well, that's a big and
long and complicated story.
One thing is I think
that there is something
about appealing to ethics.
And also you're asking doctors
to sign an oath of loyalty
to their client.
I was proposing
in one of my books
that right now we have a tax
subsidy for financial advice,
that is it's
deductible, but I think
that we should make two
changes in that deductibility.
One is it should be a tax
credit rather than a deduction,
because the people who need
financial advice the most
are low income who generally
don't have any advantage
to itemizing.
The other thing is that I
think financial advisors should
get a government
subsidy of this form
only if they sign
an oath of loyalty
to their client meaning that
they will not steer them
toward products that are
more lucrative for them.
So that would create, I think
a financial advice profession
that resembles the
medical profession.
I think most doctors don't
schedule you for surgery
that you don't need.
And that's especially
true, because they
have signed some kind of oath.
And they could be
sued for malpractice.
So it's partly a fear, but
I think it goes beyond that.
People do have some morals.
And if you said you
would do something,
you probably would just,
most people will just do it.
So buying up drugs and
raising the price, that
is something that we,
it was in the news
recently for an
outrageous example.
I can think of free market
justifications for that
if that additional profits
would then eventually
go to more drug research
that would help.
Maybe it's expensive
to do the research,
and so maybe some
drugs have to be high.
AUDIENCE: The
government funds it.
ROBERT SHILLER:
Well, anyway, you've
brought an example of
a questionable activity
that I don't have
answers to all of them.
This book is just a
general thought piece
that's supposed to change
people's deep assumptions
about the free market.
I think I'm out of time.
Is that right?
OK, well, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]